and back in this country President Biden
is meeting with Congressional leaders
later today in an effort to find a way
to raise the government debt limit and
avoid a potentially catastrophic default
at O'Keeffe is at the White House
following all of it Ed don't call it a
negotiation they say good morning that's
right heading into this meeting Tony the
only thing both sides seem to agree on
is that the faulting would be
economically catastrophic the leaders of
the House and Senate will be here to
discuss money already borrowed and the
fact that now the bills are due
Republicans are trying to use this as a
chance to make big cuts in federal
spending their plan would cut about
three trillion dollars over the next
decade including some Biden
Administration priorities like climate
change initiatives the president and
most Democrats say Congress needs to
authorize raising the borrowing limit
with no strings attached if things don't
get sorted out in the coming weeks the
President says he hasn't ruled out
invoking a little-known part of the 14th
amendment that says the validity of the
U.S debt shall not be questioned
regardless of how much has been
authorized Congress has to move quickly
if this point the treasury secretary
says the U.S could run out of money to
pay its debts as soon as June 1st and
they're just a handful of days left this
month when the house and Senator are
both scheduled to be in town at the same
time Nate which means they may have to
add a few to the calendar or somehow
kick this down the road
um Ed thank you